Olá pessoal tudo bem boa noite sejam
bem-vindos a mais uma live dos
apoiadores vamos discutir com os artigos
aqui partir paraas perguntas tá tem uma
situação que tá me preocupando bastante
Ultimamente tenho visto uns artigos
saírem sobre isso Eu até comentei em
live anterior sobre
microplástico bem no site do mercola
saiu essa semana também um artigo
baseado nisso
Eu recomendo que vocês assistam esse
documentário que
está deixa eu ver qual que é a rede que
está no
bitot eu posso colocar o link para vocês
né o bitot é uma dessas redes
alternativas ao YouTube Então esse
documentário se chama we all Plastic
people Now ou seja somos todos homens de
plástico pessoas de plástico agora n
esse documentário expõe uma verdade Tur
badora sobre a crise do plástico seus
impactos devastadores no meio ambiente e
no ser humano então nós estamos achando
partículas de plástico em bebês em
placentas dentro do coração dentro do
cérebro então é muito assustador isso
então esse que o documentário revela
como nos tornamos a personificação do
lixo que criamos carregando em nossos
corpos os químicos derivados de plástico
então
Vamos explorar os principais pontos
abordados nesse documentário que eu
recomendo que vocês assistam pen por
volta de uma hora de
duração Então vamos falar sobre esses
perigos sobre os microplásticos e
possíveis soluções para esse
problema nós sabemos já falei isso em
vídeos anteriores que os plásticos
contém disruptores endócrinos são
substâncias químicas que interferem nos
hormônios naturais do corpo então esses
podem causar problemas graves em funções
fisiológicas Especialmente na
fertilidade
masculina mas também pode alterar
crescimento alterar o
metabolismo estudos mostraram que a
presença de microplásticos diversos
tecidos
humanos incluindo cérebro pulmões rins
fígado e coração e a presença desses
microplásticos e nosso corpo indica um
problema de contaminação profunda e
abrangente
então tem aí uma
pessoa Envolvida com a realização desse
documentário chama-se hor fielding esse
cidadão testou o sangue de quatro
gerações da sua família revelando mais
de 80 químicos derivados de plástico
Então os resultados mostraram a presença
de carcinógenos disruptores endócrinos
que são o quê são substâncias que tem no
plástico que atrapalham os
receptores dos hormônios causando então
várias distorções aí nas mensagens
químicas desses hormônios né geralmente
eles provocam o quê aumento de peso
obesidade e infertilidade né além de
causar problemas
neurodegenerativos então esses achados
né dessa família sublimam a gravidade da
exposição contínua aos Plásticos e seus
subprodutos então tem vários ruptores
endócrinos mais famosos com o bpa que o
bisfenol a os falat o
PCB Eles mimetizam Eles imitam os
hormônios então eles podem tanto
estimular o receptor hormonal como
bloquear o receptor hormonal e
geralmente ele faz as duas coisas
interferem nos hormônios do nosso corpo
então esses ruptores são capazes de
causar cânceres sensíveis ao estrogênio
Tem muita gente aí com câncer de mama de
ovário pondo culpa em outros fatores
quando na verdade o problema são
disruptores
endócrinos esse químicos são
frequentemente encontrados em
microplásticos e representam uma ameaça
significativa à saúde pública antes eu
falava só assim olha não esquenta sua
comida em recipiente plástico não coloca
plástico na geladeira e infelizmente o
problema tá mais profundo do que isso né
simplesmente você não esquentar a comida
no plástico ou não colocar o plástico na
geladeira então nós sabemos que tá
acontecendo um declínio muito grande da
contagem de esperm espermatozoide e isso
tá sendo atribuído à exposição aos
fitatos que afetam os órgãos
reprodutivos masculinos e femininos a
exposição a esses químicos pode levar
uma diminuição das Diferenças sexuais do
homem para mulher resultando em
indivíduos menos completamente
masculinos ou femininos Isso é uma
preocupação crescente para a saúde
reprodutiva das futuras
gerações então a produção e descarte de
plástico está aumentando rapidamente
superando a capacidade de reciclagem
então obviamente uma solução possível
para esse problema dos microplásticos
seria a reciclagem né E também reduzir o
uso desse material que provavelmente só
vai acontecer com muita conscientização
porque hoje em dia é muito pouco falar
desse assunto tem que ser falado muito
mais para as pessoas começarem a parar
de usar produtos plásticos e optarem por
alternativas reutilizáveis como é o caso
do
vidro é importante também que as pessoas
se conscientizem para começar a
pressionar os governos e as indústrias
por mudanças então tem uma região lá no
sul dos Estados Unidos no estado da
lênia Ela é conhecida como cancer alley
é um vale lá onde tem
eh várias indústrias petroquímicas e
essa região tem uma uma taxa de câncer
50 vezes maior devido à presença de
plantas né de fábricas que químicas de
especialmente aí da indústria
petroquímica e também de plástico então
a exposição a esses produtos está
associado a estresse oxidativo
inflamação danos ao DNA são todosos
mecanismos que estão Associados a
carcinogênes a formação do Câncer Então
as estratégias paraa gente poder reduzir
essa exposição a plástico que eu
recomendo a vocês evite tomar água em
garrafa plástica evite tomar
refrigerante de modo geral mas
especialmente o refrigerante em garrafa
plástica tente utilizar garrafa de vidro
que é reutilizável mais mais seguro
eh tente utilizar sistemas de filtragem
de água com sistema de
eh mais sofisticado de filtragem né
Sistema de filtragem adequados e ferva
água para poder remover microplásticos
isso é uma coisa que eu aprendi agora
ente também não sabia que ferver água
poderia ter esse efeito aí mas ferver
água parece que ajuda a remover os
microplásticos tentar usar também o
filtro de osmose reversa né optar por
alternativas reutilizáveis evitar itens
de uso único como canudo de plástico Ná
em casa mesmo tem canosos de aço que as
crianças usam né e evitar de usar ess
colola plástica n sa colola
e permanente pro supermercado para fazer
asas não aquec alimentos em plástico
como eu já comentei em várias ocasiões
usar cerâmica vidro né Eh escolher
roupas de fibras naturais preferir roupa
de algodão de seda de cânhamo
lã outros materiais que não sejam
derivados aí da indústria petroquímica
então só somente fazer isso já vai
minimizar o problema mas não vai
resolver então é importantíssima a
mudança coletiva né incentivar empresas
e governos a mudarem o uso de plástico
descartáveis seria crucial Então mas
começar com pequenas ações como não
comprar produtos embalados em plástico
também pode fazer uma grande diferença
ser adotado por um número suficiente de
pessoas então assistam esse documentário
All Plastic people Now colocar aqui o o
link
desse documentário aqui nas mensagens
e o próximo assunto que a gente vai
discutir aqui que é relacionado a esse
tema que eu acabei de falar que é o
aumento galopante da infertilidade
Global né que é Um Desafio crescente
para a
sustentabilidade populacional tem vários
países do mundo já que tá tendo
crescimento
negativo isso por exemplo acontece no
Japão que é um país que apesar de ser de
primeiro mundo tá estagnado já há mais
de 20 anos a parte econômica e se
continuar dessa maneira o país vai
entrar em colapso até porque eles não
gostam muito de receber ondas
migratórias né o que eu não acho errado
da parte deles né porque a cultura deles
é muito peculiar e uma onda de migração
poderia destruir a cultura
deles então a questão da infertilidade
Global emergiu Então como dos desafios
maiores que nós temos agora no século XX
segundo um relatório publicado na
revista de lenet até 20100 97% dos
países não conseguirão sustentar suas
populações Devido à queda n taxas de
fertilidade então Vamos explorar as
causas consequências e possíveis
soluções Então esse Panorama da
infertilidade global é totalmente
alarmante de acordo com a organização
Mundial de Saúde atualmente um em cada
seis pessoas em todo mundo enfrenta
problemas de infertilidade é um número
bastante alto um em cada seis e nos
Estados Unidos 9% dos homens e 11% das
mulheres estão lutando com questões de
fertilidade com muitas pessoas
recorrendo a tratamentos
de reprodução assistida
né E quais seriam os principais fatores
contribuintes acabei de falar um deles
né que o que é o plástico os disruptores
endócrinos que estão nos plásticos mas
outra causa são os campos
eletromagnéticos radiação de
rádiofrequência a exposição a
eletromagnetismo especialmente aí de
ondas de rádio né de torre de celular de
outras fontes semelhantes como torre de
transmissão e também a radiação
dispositivos como celulares wi-fi está
ligado a uma diminuição significativa na
contagem de esperma em homens estudos
mostram que homens que usam celulares
mais de 20 vezes por dia apresentam
concentrações de esperm
significativamente menores né Já falamos
dos fital atos e bisfenóis e e também no
artigo anterior que são encontrados em
Plásticos e produtos de cuidado pessoal
são grandes vilões na queda de
fertilidade substâncias como metais
pesados pesticidas de aditivos
alimentares TM um impacto negativo
direto na saúde reprodutiva e o contato
diário com esses tóxicos pode levar uma
admissão na qualidade e quantidade de
gameta tanto feminino quanto
masculino existe também uma categoria de
químicos persistentes né que os
americanos chamam de forever chemicals
também na sigla pfas pfas eles são
utilizados em embalagem de alimentos e
roupa
e são conhecidos por sua capacidade de
acumulação no organismo e seus efeitos
adversos na fertilidade Então como é que
a gente faz para mitigar esse
problema em relação à dieta e Nutrição
optar por alimentos naturais alimentos
não processados como vocês estão
cansados de saber e de preferência os
orgânicos reduzir a exposição a
pesticidas aditivos utilizar alimentos
cicos em zinco o zinco ele é bom para
aumentar a testosterona também é bom
para aumentar a imunidade a fertilidade
Então os caipiras são ricos em zinco
brócolis romã isso pode ajudar a
melhorar a qualidade do esperma
exercícios regulares também ajudam
também a fazer o detox e também ajudam a
manter o peso ideal e melhorar a saúde
reprodutiva em
geral estudos indicam que pelo menos 30
minutos de exercícios três vezes por
semana podem aumentar a contagem de
esperma técnica de gerenciamento do
estresse yoga meditação né outras
técnicas como o eft podem reduzir o
estresse que é um fator importante que
pode impactar a
fertilidade minimizar a exposição a
tóxicos evitar produtos com químicos
desreguladores endócrinos né como eu já
comentei procure ler rótulos evitar
produtos que contê ftalatos e bisfenóis
e também evitar o plástico na medida do
possível como eu já
comentei substitua produtos de limpeza e
cuidados pessoais por alternativas
naturais reduzir exposição a
eletromagnetismo não carreg o celular
junto ao corpo tente usar o mínimo
possível o celular usa també o viva voz
for
possível Desligue o wi-fi à noite o
roteador minimize uso dispositivos
eletrônicos no seu
quarto faça obviamente checkups
regulares com o seu médico
fique aí a sua fertilidade o homem pode
fazer exam de espermograma caso ainda
tenha interesse ser
pai mulheres também devem monitorar a
saúde ginecológica prevenir condições
como endometriose cada vez mais comum
nas mulheres e tem a ver também com ação
ambiental e também a síndrome de ovários
policísticos também outra condição que
tem predominância estrogênica tem a ver
também com intoxicação ambiental
terceiro ponto que eu queria falar com
vocês é sobre um alimento que também eu
descobri há pouco tempo que é o Rabano
picante ou rábano Silvestre na verdade
não é rabanete é rábano tá é parecido
com rabanete e ele é um poderoso
antibiótico natural que é interessante
que vocês conheçam Então esse produto
rábano picante ou rábano Silvestre é um
vegetal de raiz que é muitas vezes
desconhecido ou subestimado el tem
propriedades interessantes medicinais
que podem contribuir pra saúde então
desde o tratamento de doenças
respiratórias até prevenção do câncer
esse poderoso alimento merece o lugar
destaque Então esse alimento contém
contém compostos naturais que ajudam a
combater uma variedade de doenças então
ele é interessante pro tratamento de
doenças respiratórias para tratamento
também de resfriados e gripe esse rabo
não é no alívio de sintomas de
resfriados comuns e gripe devido a sua
capacidade de abrir as vias
respiratórias aliviar a congestão Ajuda
também na sinusite reduzindo a
inflamação dos seos paranasais e
proporcionando alívio para aqueles que
sofrem dessa condição crônica também
pode ser utilizado para infecções
urinárias e parasitas
intestinais o rabo no picante ou
Silvestre tem propriedades bacterianas
que pode ajudar a combater infecções
urinárias matando as bactérias ruins e
também pode eliminar parasitas
promovendo a saúde intestinal tem também
propriedades anticancerígenas porque é
rico em isotiocianatos E
glucosinolatos então os ISO
isotiocianatos são compostos que TM sido
Associados a proteção contra vários
tipos de câncer incluindo pulmão mama
intestino grosso Colon e bexiga e os
glucosinolatos também pode pode ajudar a
prevenir a formação e crescimento de
células
cancerígenas então você pode usar em
Preparações caseiras esse rábano E como
é que você faz isso
D uma dica aqui para vocês né você pode
pegar 6 cm da raiz de Rabano picante ou
Rabano Silvestre descascada e ralada
suco de limão uma colher de sopa de mel
cru orgânico misturando todos os
ingredientes em um porte hermético
deixando descansar P4 horas e pode tomar
uma colher de sopa três a quatro vezes
ao dia para aliviar os sintomas
respiratórios uma outra receita de
tônico mestre uma preparação poderosa
que pode ser utilizada para fortalecer o
sistema imunológico e os ingredientes
são 700 ml de vinagre de maçã orgânico
1/4 de xícara de alho picado 1/4 de
xícara de cebola picada duas pimentas
frescas como abaneiro picadas 1/4 de
xícara de ging fresco ralado duas
colheres de sopa de [ __ ] no picante duas
colheres de sopa de açafrão em pó ou a
raiz de açafrão equivalente então você
pode preparar processando todos os
ingredientes exceto vinagre em um
processador de alimentos batemos todos
eles juntos e transferir a mistura para
um frasco de vidro preenchendo até 2/3
do
volume adicionando também vinagre de
maçã até o topo fechar e agitar armazen
enar num local fresco e seco por até
duas semanas agitando várias vezes ao
dia então você vai deixar várias semanas
ali duas semanas e vai coar o líquido
depois disso através de um agas ou pano
fino e o líquido pode ser usado como
tônico
medicinal então para manter as
propriedades medicinais do [ __ ] no
picante recomenda-se consumir o cru ou
dessas formas que eu acabei de falar
para vocês e é interessante usar luvas
para preparar o rabo no picante porque o
manuseio dele pode causar irritação na
pele e nos olhos
Ok então vamos às
perguntas hã
primeira pergunta da
Silvana o cálculo de
triger e HDL deu C Então imagina que tá
falando da proporção de séries em
relação a HDL que o ideal que seja no
máximo dois o dela deu
5,3 o que eu posso fazer para baixar o
triglicerídeo de forma natural deixa ver
se tá dando para ver bem aqui
a tá dando para ler né deixa eu aumentar
só um pouquinho mais a tamanho da letra
aqui então para baixar os trigliceridos
tem várias estratégias a principal delas
é a dieta reduzindo carboidrato refinado
açúcar é muito importante porque os
triglicérides vê do fígado a partir do
processamento do carboidrato que não foi
adequadamente aí utilizado pelo
organismo então se você cortar
carbohidrato refinado açúcar você vai
cortar bastante o nível de
triglicerídeos do corpo tá aumentar a
ingesta de gorduras saudáveis como as
monoinsaturadas que tem no abacate e no
azeite de oliva as polens saturadas né
com os
ômega-3 é importante você comer essas
coisas nozes castanhas né aumentar as
fibras também vai ajudar
Ah porque a fibra ela reduz a absorção
de carboidrato a atividade física com
certeza vai ajudar bastante e perda de
peso através da dieta da atividade
física do Sono adequado a controle do
estresse também vai acontecer isso o
álcool né o álcool pode aumentar os
níveis de trigliceridos pelo mesmo
mecanismo porque o álcool ele é pretado
no fígado também e parte dele vai virar
e
gordura suplementos naturais que você
pode
utilizar eh o ômega-3 o óleo de peixe as
fibras solúveis com psílio e também a
berberina é uma ótima opção e o bergavit
que é o extrato de Bergamota tanto o
bergavit quanto a beberina baixo os
triglicérides do sangue
Ok tem outras coisas aí mas esses são os
principais
vamos pra próxima
aqui Antônio Renato que fez a pergunta
aqui D Alan li uma notícia que era
recomendado correr só três vezes por
semana para dar um descanso intercalar
com outros exercícios mas para quem não
tem muitas opções de exercício poderia
correr todos os dias primeiro Por que
não teria muitas opções de exercício Não
entendi bem essa colocação aqui né
correr todos os dias é possível sim se
você fizer uma alternância de
intensidade num dia você corre um
pouquinho mais intenso no outro dia você
corre mais leve você pode fazer o hit né
que você faz caminhada eh no ritmo mais
pesado alternado com corrida então é
importante você tomar alguns cuidados
para evitar lesões
o descanso pelo menos um dia por semana
é importante para permitir que os seus
músculos recuperem se for fortaleça sem
descanso adequado Você pode ter risco de
lesões e até
overtraining certo então você pode
também alternar os dias de corrida com
dias de caminhada ou fazer a a caminhada
alternada com corrida no mesmo dia mas
uma corrida mais
leve e eu não vejo muita razão para você
não fazer outros exercícios tá você não
deixou claro aqui porque não fazer
outros exercícios mas pode fazer
ciclismo pode fazer natação pode fazer
yoga pode fazer exercício funcional
Então por que não fazer outros
exercícios com musculação Talvez você
tenha uma contraindicação para fazer
musculação não sei
né então é importante ter consciência
corporal escutar o seu corpo respeitar o
seu corpo quando tiver tendo dores
crônicas Então deve levar a sério dor
persistente procurar um profissional
quando for necessário e respeitar o seu
corpo fazendo adaptação gradual dos
exercícios ok
vamos pra
próxima Antônio Renato pode tomar
beberina 500 aí eu imagino que você tá
querendo dizer 500 mg tá Antônio não é
ML né 500 mg duas ou três vezes ao dia
mesmo em jejum tem algum problema
geralmente dá para tomar beberina duas
ou três vezes ao dia sem problemas tá
beberina é muito muito bom é um
suplemento muito interessante para
controlar o açúcar do sangue para
controlar os trigliceres do sangue
também tomar beberina eem jejum pode ser
eficaz Porém você tem que tomar alguns
cuidados
tá ela realmente vai ser mais eficaz
você dividir em doses ao longo do dia do
que tentar tomar tudo de uma vez e a
dose padrão dela é essa mesmo de 1000 a
1500 MG por
dia algumas pessoas vão você desconforto
abdominal gastrointestinal usando a
beberina pode dar nuse alcoólica fica
atento quanto a
isso algumas pessoas não vão tolerar em
jejum só vão tolerar tomar beberina com
alimentos então isso também tem que ser
observado a beberina pode interagir com
alguns antihipertensivos ou outros
remédios para baixar o açúcar do sangue
tem então ficar atento com relação a
isso é possível ter diarreia constipação
ou dores abdominais ou gases assim como
a metiformina que é parecida com a
beberina Então tem que ficar atento com
relação a isso daí tá então é melhor
começar doses menores e subindo aos
poucos a dose para ver como é que você
reage obviamente fazer um acompanhamento
com um profissional que conheça esse
esse ativo aí um médico ou nutricionista
né uma família faz produtos de limpeza e
os produtos são feitos com produtos
tóxicos como lauril por exemplo como se
proteger caso a pessoa tenha suspeita de
que possa estar se intoxicando quais
suplementos
utilizar bem o que vai ser mais eficaz
aí é utilizar medidas de proteção
pessoal né os equipamentos de proteção
individual os zepi usar luva máscara
óculos de prote roupa de proteção Se for
possível tá minimamente usar aí
luvas e usar óculos de proteção se puder
usar máscara e roupa também seria melhor
ainda trabalhar em ambiente bem
ventilado também ajuda bastante a evitar
contaminação lavar bem as mãos depois de
ter contato também com esses
produtos cuidado também é monitorar
sinais sintomas de intoxicação como dor
de cabeça náusea estura irritação na
pele e nos
[Música]
olhos obviamente se você se intoxicar
agudamente procurar um serviço médico e
lavar a área afetada com água
corrente o que vai Minimizar certo não
vai resolver o problema é você utilizar
por exemplo antioxidantes como vitamina
C A vitamina E a silimarina que dá
suporte ao fígado melhora a capacidade
de detox o nac né NS cisteína também
porque precor da glota o aspico também
que tem uma um papel interessante como
antioxidante e agente detox msm também
pode ajudar né o metil sulfon metano o
zinco e o selênio també pode ajudar em
algumas circunstâncias a clorela
probióticos
tá Então essas são as medidas aí
importantes
Existe algum problema em correr todos os
dias 30 a 40 minutos sem Descanso já
comentei sobre isso né então novamente
Depende se você fizer uma corrida leve e
alternar com corridas mais fortes em
outros dias e fazer essa alternância
entre andar e caminhar Você pode até
conseguir fazer isso sem muitos
problemas mas mesmo assim eu recomendo
que descanse pelo menos um dia da semana
certo
algumas pessoas podem desenvolver
fratura por Estresse pode desenvolver
tendinite pode desenvolver faite plantar
uma outra condição chama síndrome da
banda
iliotibial toma cuidado com isso daí
Ok Tenta diversificar mais seu treino
como eu já falei ciclismo natação
musculação funcional etc pilates ok
próximo pironi provoca ou agrava
disfunção sexual disfunção erétil
potência sexual sim né Peroni pode
causar disfunção erétil
ok que que é Peroni para quem não sabe é
uma condição em que acontece uma
calcificação um tecido cicatricial
fibroso no pênis e dependendo da posição
dessa calica vai causar uma curvatura
então p fica torto e muitas vezes tem
dor na penetração e tem às vezes
impossibilidade de penetrar Pelo Grau de
curvatura e dependendo de da extensão
dessa falsificação dessa fibrose vai
alterar a circulação sanguínea dentro do
pênis e causar a disfunção
erétil porque o tecido cicatricial ele
vai atrapalhar a entrada de sangue né na
na parte sinusoidal ali dos copos CAV
e não vai deixar o corpo cabeloso se
encher de sangue de uma forma eficiente
então ele também interfere na
elasticidade e na capacidade do pênis se
expandir durante uma ereção e a própria
curvatura peniana atrapalha muitas vezes
a penetração causando dor ou impedindo a
penetração e o próprio fator psicológico
também né a presença dessas placas dessa
curvatura pode causar impacto grande aí
psicológico de ansiedade estresse
diminuição da autoestima que pode causar
também disfunção erétil
Ok então é muito importante assim que
você descobrir que tem esse problema que
você já faça um tratamento imediatamente
tá para começar aí um tratamento seguro
seria o uso de cicina e de tocotrienóis
né vitamina e mas eu especificamente eu
acho que é mais eficiente os
tocotrienois do Urucum existe injeções
locais que podem ser feitas também com
verapamil que é bloqueador de cálcio o
colagenas que pode ajudar o ozone pode
ajudar certo potaba também pode ajudar
vi oral eh tem dispositivos de tração
peniana que geralmente são usados para
aumentar o pênis mas pode ajudar a
corrigir a curvatura melhorar a função
erétil mais modernamente terapia de onda
de choque também pode ajudar
em casos mais graves que você tentou
pelo menos um ano de tratamento não teve
um bom resultado pode fazer cirurgias né
que tanto Pode ser plicatura que é a
cirurgia de
nesbit no enxerto peniano E caso também
mais grave pode e utilizar prótese
peniana especialmente caso que tem uma
disfunção erétil
aí mais
importante é perigoso realizar corrida
de alta intensidade todos os dias de
novo a mesma pergunta comer alimentos
não saudáveis a corrida pode se tornar
algo mal por causa os alimentos não
saudáveis bem da corrida já não vou nem
comentar porque eu já falei duas vezes
né Veja bem se você comer uma
alimentação muito inflamatória o que que
vai acontecer você vai ter depressão de
vitaminas do complexo
B e isso vai atrapalhar até a sua
recupera do exercício
né É muito importante que você tenha
essa preocupação de ter uma alimentação
saudável com nutrientes essenciais que
uma alimentação pobre nutrientes vai
levar a problema do sistema imune você
vai ficar doente não vai conseguir
correr direito essa deficiência de
minerais também vão afetar sua
recuperação muscular sua saúde geral e
aumentar sua
inflamação e vai dificultar a
recuperação Eu vou atender o telefone
que a minha esposa tá ligando aqui
alô não eu tô no meio da
Live Tá
bom você quiser vir aqui tá bom
e também quando você come alimentos
ricos em açúcar né você vai ter Picos e
quedas bruscas de energia no seu corpo
isso não vai fazer mal para você também
né então é importantíssimo ter uma dieta
adequada junto com a atividade
física Então não é uma boa ideia fazer
isso
ok Antônio Renato
urina Clara significa sempre que a
pessoa está hidratada nem sempre tá nem
sempre tá a cor da urina pode dar
informações úteis sobre o estado de
hidratação mas a urina Clara não é
sempre que a pessoa está adequadamente
hidratada lógico quando a pessoa está
hidratada a urina tende a ser mais clara
um amarelo palha Amarelo
pálido porém se você se hidratar de
forma ex
também pode causar problemas tá você
pode ter uma hiponatremia dilucional
cair muito sódio do sangue e causar
problemas isso tá
aí então é importante que você distribua
o líquido ao longo do dia Não Beba muita
água de uma vez e alguns alimentos e
bebidas podem afetar a cor da urina por
exemplo café e algumas variedades de chá
tem efeito diurético aumenta a produção
de urina e potencialmente vai ar mais
porque você vai ter esse efeito
diurético e medicamentos diuréticos
também vão ter o mesmo efeito né e clar
não quer dizer que você tá
hidratado existe uma doença rara que
chamada de diabetes insípidos que é
falta do hormônio antidiurético e isso
causa produção excessiva de urina devido
a incapacidade do corpo de concentrar a
urina Então essa é uma doença tem que
ser tratada
bem vamos pra próxima
pergunta uma dica de máscara para
pessoas que trabalham com produtos de
limpeza que por conta disso lidam com
produtos tóxicos tá tem várias aí a
marca mais conhecida é a marca 3M né Tem
uns modelos aí que eu posso colocar na
tela para
vocês deixa eu colocar aqui para vocês
na
tela não sei se vai aparecer tudo de uma
vez
aí tá pessoal de uma lida aí nos nos
comentários não vou colocar na tela não
porque vai ficar muito grande na tela tá
tem uma outra chada rell tá que é
interessante
também colocar
aqui outra que chama-se
modex E outro que se chamae gvs tá na
dúvida vai na 3M que é uma marca mais
fácil de
encontrar Vamos paraa próxima uma
pergunta ansiedade em alta intensidade
pode desencadear infarto obviamente que
sim né aumenta a produção de adrenalina
aumenta a produção de
cortisol isso pode causar um problema
sim sabemos que a ansiedade tem impactos
significativos na saúde
cardiovascular ela por si só pode
aumentar a pressão arterial né porque a
ansiedade pode aumentar a frequência
cardíaca e a pressão arterial aumentar a
liberação dos hormônios do estresse que
eu já comentei cortisol e adrenalina
isso pode causar constrição dos vasos
sanguíneos e aumento da pressão
arterial o estresse crônico também pode
provocar inflamação que está tá
associado ao desenvolvimento de doenas
cardiovasculares pessoas que TM Muita
ansiedade também T comportamentos de
risco como beber mais tomar mais
eh usar álcool em excesso alimentação em
excesso
e muitas vezes também as pessoas
ansiosas tendem a ser
sedentárias em casos raros um ataque de
pânico Severo pode ar um infarto Gudo do
miocárdio
e muitas vezes a ansiedade pode simular
um infarto dando dor no peito e a pessoa
parar no pronto soc com suspeita de
infarto mas na verdade era só uma crise
de pânico nesso é muito mais comum na
verdade
ok é importante fazer mindfulness
meditação tá chante cum para poder
controlar essa ansiedade não ter
problemas todos que nós estamos
comentando a atividade física obviamente
ajuda muito também para controlar o
estress e psicoterapia né pessoal
obviamente uma pergunta de corrida n
pessoa que tá obsecado com corrida
aqui corrida de alta intensidade aliado
uma alimentação saudável baixa LDL 150
Sim ajuda a baixar Um dos fatores que
baixa o LDL o colesterol é a atividade
física a atividade física intensa
estudos mostraram que aumenta o HDL
colesterol e baixa o LDL colesterol
Ok obviamente que a alimentação vai ter
um papel muito mais potente do que a
atividade física mas a atividade física
vai ajudar bastante ok
Como identificar prováveis problemas
cardíacos na corrida de alta
intensidade bem é importante você tá
atento às coisas mais óbvias né se você
tiver dor no peito pode ser uma angina e
geralmente descrito como uma sensação de
pressão aperto ou dor no centro do peito
que pode caminhar irradiar braço pescoço
PR mandíbula ou paraas costas se tiver
isso durante uma atividade física parae
imediatamente vai ao hospital falta de
ar também é a mesma coisa se for uma
falta de ar desproporcional o esforço
pode ser um problema aí relacionado ao
pulmão ou trombose pulmonar palpitações
com batimentos cardíacos irregulares
também é um fator de
risco tontura ou Vertigem também é um
fator de risco tem que ficar atento
desmaiar também não precisa nem dizer
excesso de suor também que é
desproporcional o esforço físico se
continuar persistentemente tem que porar
assistência médica e náuseas e vômitos
né Eh se for uma coisa que acontece com
muita frequência também tem que procurar
assistência
médica importante também para quem quer
ser corredor tem que fazer uma avaliação
médica prévia né fazer exames
cardiológicos exames metabólicos do
sangue Ok tem que fazer isso para poder
fazer com segurança obviamente
né E também cuidado na no treinamento
aumentar a intensidade de forma
gradual é bom usar também aí um
dispositivo no no pulso né para
monitorar a frequência cardíaca ou até
mesmo aqueles que coloca no peito que é
mais preciso ainda né que se comunica
com relógio
certo a próxima
pergunta tomo copos de 350 ml
aproximadamente de uma vez À vezes tomo
dois ou três Quais os problemas para
minha
saúde então como eu já comentei agora eh
beber grandes quantidades de água de uma
vez só pode diluir o sangue levar
hiponatremia
dilucional que isso pode até dar
problema no coração dependendo da
pessoa pode também causar náuseas dor de
cabeça confusão mental em casos mais
graves convulsões e coma então é melhor
você dividir mais ao longo do dia tá do
que fazer isso de uma vez tá então não
recomendo você tome mais de 1 l de água
assim de uma vez só obviamente que a
maioria das pessoas não vai ter problema
com isso mas não vale a pena correr o
risco almoçar e deitar-se após o almoço
faz mal sim porque atrapalha a digestão
e facilita refluxo
gastroesofágico então você pode ter
problema de refluxo porque você deitou
imediatamente depois de comer porque
essa posição deitada Ela facilita o
retorno do ao para o esôfago queimando o
esôfago então é importante é recomendado
que você aguarde pelo menos 30 minutos
antes de deitar para permitir a digestão
adequada e reduzir o risco de
desconforto abdominal ou gastro
intestinal acordar 5 horas da manhã e na
mesma hora tomar banho com água fria
para ir para a caminhada pode trazer mal
e acordar e após acordar tomar um copo
de água pode fazer
mal tomar banho com água fria aou
acordar à 5 horas da manhã isso aí
geralmente tá eu comentei isso em vídeos
recentes tá esse choque térmico em
pessoas saudáveis ela pode ser sim
interessante porque dá uma estimulada
nas sirtuínas através daito Protein
né choque térmico e pessoas que estão
saudáveis pode ajudar na saúde e na
prevenção aí de algumas doenças mas para
algumas pessoas que não estão
acostumadas pode ser um choque pro corpo
né então tem que ficar atento
mas de modo geral pode até melhorar a
circulação e aumentar a sobrevida não
sei se vocês já viram os vídeos de uma
mulher no YouTube uma mulher bonita até
jovem que deve morar num lugar muito
frio eu não sei se ela mora na Rússia
provavelmente ela mora ali na na Sibéria
e ela no meio da neve ela vai tomar
banho numa espécie de caixa d'água lá
cheia de gelo né mas essa mulher para
fazer isso ela deve estar muito bem
treinada
né tomar um copo de água fria é
totalmente seguro ajuda na hidratação Ok
não vejo problema em relação a isso aí
OK uma pessoa inicia a corrida às 5
horas da manhã
e mas o sol ainda não apareceu só vai
aparecer às 5:20 ou 5:30 mesmo assim
nosso circo circadiano é ciclo tá não é
circo não cirlo circadiano reconhece que
Acordamos mesmo que esteja nublado sim
vai reconhecer porque o ritmo cadian não
é só influenciado pela luz mas também
outros fatores como atividade física
também vão desempenhar um papel em
acordar o seu
corpo mesmo quando a gente começa a
correr antes do nascer do sol põ dias
nublados atividade física e exposição a
luz natural mesmo que seja de forma
indireta através de nuvens vai ajudar a
regular o seu ciclo cardiano
o seu ritmo
Cardano sinalizando ao corpo que é hora
de estar acodado e
ativo quando são 5 da manhã a casa está
escuro então a pessoa acende a luz
artificial Esse é o primeiro contato da
pessoa com luz mas o ideal deveria ser a
luz natural o fato de não ser natural
pode prejudicar o sono então obviamente
que tem exposição à luz natural mas a
exposição à luz artificial acordar
também pode
ajudar em menor grau do que a luz
natural Mas pode ajudar a regular o
ritmo
Cardano e a luz azul das lâmpadas LED
fluorescentes pode ser suficiente para
ajudar a acordar mas a exposição
excessiva a luz artificial especialmente
à noite vai atrapalhar interferir no
sono então para minimizar os efeitos
negativos é é interessante buscar a luz
natural o mais cedo possível pela manhã
e limitar a exposição à luz artificial à
noite marca de sabonete natural que não
prejudicam a
saúde tem a Granado ela tem produtos
interessantes sentes naturais gradientes
vegetais sem
parabeno tem uma linha da Granada
chamado terapeutic
que é interessante tem o litan
obesil perdoem meu francês mas o litan é
interessante oferece uma linha de
produtos inspirados na biodiversidade
brasileira também tem produtos naturais
a reserva fólio também tem ingredientes
naturais e orgânicos tem uma marca
chamado feito
Brasil Arte dos aromas e Cativa a
natureza tá são marcas interessantes aí
você diz que homens jovens com
impotência sexual podem apresentar no
futuro problemas
cardiovasculares pois a falta de ereção
e um problema de circulação sanguínea eh
talvez você não tenha entendido
totalmente na verdade a impotência
sexual é um marcador de possíveis
problemas cardíacos no futuro tá não é
que a impotência causou o problema
cardiovascular na verdade El ele é um
mar ador é um surrogate tá ele é um um
aviso uma uma bandeirinha dizendo que o
sistema cardiovascular da pessoa já não
tá uma beleza
tá nós sabemos que disfunção herética em
homens jovens pode ser um indicador
precó de problemas cardiovasculares
futuros a ereção Depende de bom fluxo
sanguíneo problemas de ereção podem
refletir problemas de circulação que
também afeta o coração então um marcador
tá estudos mostram que função herético
pode preceder doenças cardiovasculares
como arterosclerose em cerca de 5 anos
então portanto é importante você
considerar levar a série disfunção eré
não só apenas com um problema de
qualidade de vida mas um possível sinal
de alerta para problemas
cardiovasculares e se tiver o problema
buscar uma avaliação médica abrangente
para ver se não tem um problema em
outros territórios
arteriais já ouviu falar no no
a masturbação compulsiva todos os dias
pode trazer algum mal à saúde mental do
homem assim como a pornografia tem um
pesquisador chamado Gary Wilson que tem
o site
yourbrainonporn.com fala que a
pornografia causa impotência sexual e
que muitos homens estão nessa situação
nesse caso seria qualquer estímulo
sexual visual qual sua opinião sobre
isso bem Eu já li artigos sobre isso e é
fato sim tá que a masturbação causa
distorções na percepção do homem eh
sobre o ato sexual e isso a longo prazo
pode causar disfunção erétil sim tá isso
é uma discussão muito frequente hoje em
dia sobre a masturbação
compulsiva e o abuso da
pornografia Especialmente na saúde
sexual e na saúde mental dos homens
Então quais são os efeitos negativos da
masturbação pulsiva na saúde mental eh
pode levar sentimento de culpa vergonha
ansiedade pode interferir em atividades
diárias impactando a saúde
mental E tem alguns pesquisadores
dizendo que se você fizer de uma maneira
bem equilibrada e controlada a
masturbação poderia ter um efeito até
Positivo tá sem excesso de
pornografia e relação também à parte
física pode causar irritação lesões
na genitália se feito de forma
agressiva em casos muito raros pode
levar até problema de disfunção erétil
direta por lesões né no órgão
masculino Então existe estudos mostrando
o impacto da pornografia então Gary
Wilson esse pesquisador que você
comentou aí e outro sugere que o consumo
sensível de pornografia pode levar
dessensibilização ao estímulo sexual
real ou seja a pessoa f fic tão assim
acostumada com aquelas modelos com
aquelas pessoas assim eh realmente com
uma estética muito acima do normal ela
pode ter uma dessensibilização ao mundo
real resultando em disfunção herético já
seria um mecanismo não mecânico
exatamente mas um mecanismo mais de
estimulação e também a pornografia causa
expectativas irrealistas sobre o sexo o
desempenho sexual porque realmente o
tempo que eles ficam lá é um tempo
eh artificial né eles têm vários
recursos lá para ficar um tempo
prolongado isso pode causar uma
impressão na pessoa de que as pessoas em
geral são assim
né e o uso excessivo de pornografia
também leva problemas de relacionamento
de relações interpessoais a pessoa fica
mais isolada
socialmente certo vamos partir para
outro assunto que esse pode ser até meio
constrangedor ou agressivo para algumas
pessoas assisti um vídeo sobre saúde que
estava falando sobre vitamina D3 e
mencionou o caso de duas pessoas que
estavam tomando de 8 a 12.000 unidades
de vitamina D3 por dia por dois anos
desenvolveram problemas renais na sua
opinião os danos
renais Possivelmente foram por outra
razão ou tem pessoas ou certas condições
que associadas a certas doses de
vitamina D3 podem levar danos sim é
totalmente possível tá não é a dose que
é o mais importante mas é o nível
sanguíneo de vitamina D isso varia de
pessoa para pessoa com doses diferentes
tá então é totalmente possível que nessa
dose de 8 a a 12.000 unidades por dia
sem nenhum controle exame de sangue pode
causar hipervitaminose D hi emia que é
excesso de cálcio no sangue e esse
excesso de cálcio no sangue pode
acumular em vários órgãos levando a
vários danos diferentes inclusive danos
renais então a hipercalcemia pode que é
o excesso de cálcio no sangue pode levar
a náusea vômito
fraqueza em casos graves até
coma e esse acúmulo de cálcio nos INSS
pode levar a nefrocalcinose e também a a
pedras do rim né pedras renais e a
calcinose que é o depósito de cálcio no
parena renal pode levar ess
renal tem pessoas que são muito mais
sensíveis né a dose de elevada de
vitamina D do que outras então não deve
usar sem monitoramento
médio e outras doenças como sarcoidose
que uma doença Rara ou
hiperparatiroidismo ou tuberculose podem
aumentar a sensibilidade ao excesso de
vitamina D e aumentar o risco de
hipercalcemia
Então tem que ser monitorado qualquer
pessoa que estiver utilizando doses
dessa magnitude e muitas vezes tem que
suspender também temporariamente a
vitamina
D para períodos curtos de estresse de
uma duas semanas como entrevista exames
quais suplementos teriam um efeito mais
rápido no controle da ansiedade estess
comprei um suplemento fax Ganda rodiola
basel deve ser rly basel bacopa mas na
embalagem diz tomar por seis semanas no
mínimo para ter efeitos estou usando l
teanina e magnésio já teria algo mais
para recomendar bem primeiro que a
rodiola não é exatamente para isso tá a
rodiola é um adaptógeno Então mas não é
exatamente um calmante tá a chaga tem um
efeito mais calmante do que a rodiola e
a bacopa também é mais para do que para
acalmar
tá então os suplementos que vão ter o
alívio mais rápido um deles é lanina que
você já tá
utilizando você pode aumentar a dose da
lanina para 200 mg três vezes ao dia né
caso você não tá tendo um efeito muito
imediato com a dose que você tá
utilizando o magnésio também tem um
efeito mais rápido você pode usar também
a Valeriana e a pass Flora eles ajudam
também e o gaba tá o gaba tem uma versão
modificada que é a offen boot que
ofendeu o
gaba mas esse você não vai conseguir sem
receita e o gaba eh também ajuda a
acalmar o cérebro Porque ele é o
aminoácido neurotransmissor calmante e
também você pode usar óleo essencial de
lavanda também ajuda a a acalmar ok
tenham visto métodos que alegam parar o
soluço imediatamente beber água fechar o
ouvido nariz ao mesmo tempo tomar um
susto prender a respiração Você conhece
suplemento que para o soluço não não
conheço
Ok Quais são as causas do soluço esses
métodos comuns aí que você comentou
beber água fechar o ouvido nariz
simultaneamente tomar susto perder a
respiração 10 segundos podem ajudar sim
tá
agora nenhum suplemento vai suspender
imediatamente soluço Mas pode usar por
exemplo magnésio a efeito vai ser a mais
a médio e longo prazo Mas pode ajudar a
camomila também mesma
situação e as causas de soluço irritação
do diafragma por espasmos involuntários
desse músculo né o músculo da respiração
e seguido pelo fechamento rápido das
cordas vocais que que produz aquele som
né então um espasmo de diafragma e
fechamento das cordas locais Tá mas
gastrite pode provocar também e refluxo
e o refluxo pode irritar o diafragma
então gastrite ou refluxo podem causar
soluços comer ou beber água muito rápido
causa soluços que é mais comum uso de
bebidas com gás mudança brusca de
temperatura estresse excitação emocional
sobre o zinco suplemento zinco tem que
ser em cápsul gás resistente não não é
obrigatório que seja tá isso é mais é
proteger o estômago de queimação que tem
muita gente que tem queimação com zinco
mas não é todo mundo o suplementos em
carnosina da Doctor best que lado Sim
carnosina já é aminoácido aqu lado Sim
esse mesmo suplemento eh cápsula
gastroresistente Não não é cá a cápsula
gastr resistente o l opt zinc da n Foods
É zinc
quelado sim ele é uma forma desen
quelado porque ele tá ligado a
aminoácido metionina Ok mas ele não é
gast resistente também não
semana passada você postou um vídeo
sobre creatina no qual você disse que
combinar creatina com carbohidrato
complexo e proteínas potencializa o
efeito da creatina eu pensei que fosse
somente carboidratos não sabia que teria
que tomar proteína que tem que tomar
proteína Eliseu ele ajuda também tá não
é obrigatório não tá creatina em doses
muito baixas 1 g por exemplo pode ser
consumido sem quebrar o jejum sim
Tecnicamente não vai quebrar o jejum 1 g
de de cre não e a combinação de creatina
com carboidratos e proteínas vão
aumentar a absorção pelos músculos desse
elemento os carbohidratos vão aumentar a
insulina que facilita o transporte de
creatina para as células musculares e
muitos aminoácidos vão ter o mesmo
efeito não vai ajudar
sim estudos sugerem que a combinação de
creatina com proteínas e carboidratos V
I alizar ainda mais a absorção os
efeitos da creatina tá Eu
particularmente uso creatina junto com
eprin coloco Glutamina também e coloco
banana
para ter esse efeito
aí tá demorando para
rouar eliz não sa fazer fazer uma
pergunta né tem que ser
uma uma sequência
oleaginosa ao comer uma boa quantidade
de oleaginosa ao longo do dia eu ainda
vou precisar do a para musculação
oleaginosa não é uma grande fonte de
proteína não ela tem uma quantidade
assim até razoável mas não vai
substituir proteí não na sua opinião
Qual é melhor nos borboleta ou
pecã então a no borboletas ricas em
ômega-3 antioxidantes a nos pecan também
tem antioxidantes vitaminas e minerais
mas tem menos ômega-3 do que as nosas
borboleta tá então se você tá preocupado
com omega3 a nosas borboleta vai ser
melhor am mendas cruas é melhor do que
amêndoas
defumadas quando você defuma ou torra
amêndoa pode perder algums dos
nutrientes tá
Por que que o amendoim faz mal por causa
de contaminação Por aflatoxinas que é
comum eles são suscetíveis a esse tipo
de fungo que produz essa toxina aí AF FL
toxinas que são cancerígenas
e amendoin também é muito rico em
ômega-6 não tem uma boa quantidade de
ômega-3 e são alergênicos também muitas
pessoas têm alergia ao amendoim tá então
por isso que não é o ideal
e semente amolecida ou esbranquiçada
revela a contaminação por fungo sim pode
indicar contaminação por mofo ou
[Música]
fungo pera
aí teu teléfone tocou
alô tá tô no meio da Live ainda mas vou
descer Ness você tá sem chave né porque
eu eu deixei essa chave hoje em casa lá
mas você tinha saído Tá eu vou descer aí
tá eu vou ter que me ausentar aí por uns
2 minutos pessoal já volto
JA
[Música]
Pronto estou de volta vamos lá
pedra no
rim a partir de que tamanho é impossível
remover a pedra naturalmente se é
necessário cirurgia depende tá
geralmente pedras menores de 5 a 7 MM
tem boa chance de ser espid eu já vi
gente espindo pedra de 1,5 cm mas é
raridade tá geralmente pedras acima de 7
MM tem que fazer cirurgia
num vídeo YouTube você diz que alguns
países a PED vinos é mais comum em
outros países é menos comum isso se deve
à
alimentação sim is se deve a vários
fatores o mais importante é hábitos de
vida e alimentação né então dietas muito
ricas em sódio muito ricas em proteínas
animais pode e açúcar também pode
aumentar o risco de p luins e pessoas
também que vivem em países que bebem
menos água ou que tem menos magnésio na
alimentação pode aumentar o risco de
fumação de
pedras paises mais quentes também é mais
comum né ter pedra nos INSS devido a
desidratação
ã para uma pessoa que costuma ter pedra
INSS Qual a dose preventiva de magnésio
citrato Geralmente eu
passo por volta de 5 milig por dia ou em
alguns casos com monitoramento 500 mg
duas vezes ao dia essa dose de 1 g só
com monitoramento de médico Ok não deve
usar
isso sozinho e é comum ter diarreia com
essa dose aí
OK você disse que que tem pedra nos zins
possui 31% de chance mais infarto do
miocárdio eu falei isso não tô me
recordando disso não
tá mas assim eh o infarto agudo
miocardio é mais comum quem tem
obesidade né E quem tem obesidade também
é mais comum ter pedra no rim pressão
alta também tem uma associação com pedra
nos Rin e tem Associação também com
infarto do miocárdio talvez tenha sido
Nesse contexto que eu falei isso daí
né
hã isso acontece porque o cálcio vai
para as partes moles do
corpo não não é necessariamente o cálcio
das Pedras dos í que vai para partes
moles mas sim a presença de condições
que promovem a calcificação vascular e
aterosclerose que aumenta o risco de
risco cardiovascular tá então a
calcificação de tecidos moles que pode
aumentar o risco cardiovascular
especialmente das artérias né e dos das
paredes das das câmaras cardíacas
você disse que alterações nas gorduras
do sangue tem pedra nos
índices como é que
é alterações nas gorduras do sangue tem
pedra nos
índice não sei se eu entendi esse
negócio
não tá tem alguns estudos que falam que
o consumo de gorduras trans que tem
alimentos processados pode aumentar o
risco de formação de PED nos gins tá
aumentando a inflamação Geral do
organismo Talvez seja isso que tá
querendo dizer
aí
osteoporos é mais comum em quem tem
pedra nos ZS por causa da ausência de
K2 então vitam K2 é importante para
direcionar o cálcio pros ossos né n e
também para tirar os cálcios das
artérias pessoas que TM pé nos Lins
podem ter alterações no metabolismo do
cálcio aumentando o risco de osteoporose
tá então tem uma relação Aí sim a
deficiência de vitamina K2 pode agravar
essa situação porque o cálcio não é
corretamente direcionado pros ossos
pessoal tá 1 H 10 de Live já tá
responder as dúvidas ao vivo não tá tem
muita pergunta aqui
hoje Car Dr Alan na Alemanha está
havendo um surto explosivo de Câncer com
morte na H de 700 de acréscimo tenho
filhos e netos que lá vivem temse um bom
caminho para se proteger dentro
possível é ter os bos de vida Vi Carlos
isso aí se você se referindo aí a proteí
Spike seria aquelas medidas contra
proteína Spike né usar nac usar
picnogenol natoquinase
é isso
eh dente de leão Mas são coisas ainda
também muito incipientes né mais
importante seria ter uma dieta
antiinflamatória comendo orgânico
comendo uma alimentação rica em frutas e
vegetais grãos integrais nós
sementes cotos processados
inicializados proteínas magras gorduras
saudáveis e suplementar os
micronutrientes as vitaminas conforme
necessário estilo de vida ativo com
exercícios físicos controle do estresse
meditação yoga mindfulness Son adequado
tudo que a gente fala sempre né é o que
você pode
fazer tentar minimizar a sua exposição a
toxinas ambientais como tecidos metais
pesados aquela história do plástico que
acabei de falar também na no começo da
Live tentar utilizar filtro de água né
como eu comentei filtro de ar também se
for
possível e assim em termos de su entação
os mais clássicos aí é cúrcuma né como
antiinflamatório Resveratrol chá verde
né entre vários outros
aí quais os suprimentos tá querendo
dizer acho que suplementos né que ajudam
a diminuir a
ansiedade já falei falei nessa Live é só
você voltar lá no ponto que eu falei
tá comprei o gaba e depois tive
informação de que incompatível com a Liv
tiroxina não não conheço essa informação
não tá vou até checar isso por que que
seria incompatível
né Não conheço essa informação que você
tá falando aí
não o que você tem que fazer é usar o A
levotiroxina de jejum
tá
e longe qualquer outro suplemento trans
veratrol tiamina pode ser usado de forma
contínua sim Podem sem problemas Isaac
de preferência com monitoramento
[Música]
médio ó o eliz já tá perguntando de
própolis aqui uma marca que eu recomendo
para vocês é o apis Flora tá a marca boa
de
própolis azeite de oliva Eliseu Tem
várias marcas boas são dezenas de marcas
boas não vale nem a pena ficar citando
isso tem que ler o rótulo tem que buscar
um azeite extra virgem de baixa acidez
carrafa de vidro escura tá isso aí não
vou ficar citando dezenas de macas de
azeite de oliva
não encontrei o suplemento americano no
qual o lactobacilo se alimenta não é
lactobacilo é
é é oxalobacter o nome desse bacter é
oxalobacter formen se eu não me engano
Deixa eu confirmar isso
eu acho eu falei isso num vídeo muito
antigo Inclusive tem um vídeo mais
de É isso mesmo tá é oxalobacter Formes
deixa eu mostrar na tela aqui para vocês
aqui deixa
eu
Stop share screen
tem muito tempo que eu não falo disso
nem sei como é que eu lembrei o nome
dessa bactéria tá Dá uma pesquisada no
Google isso daí tá que você vai achar
essa oxalobacter fenes
[Música]
tá
ã gente eu vou eu vou responder
rapidamente algumas perguntas aqui mas
vou encerar que tem 1 hora1 de Live já o
o que tomar para baixo homocisteína
várias coisas tá metilfolato
metilcobalamina vitamina B2 vitamina B6
creatina nac trimetilglicina
cerina
ã ômega-3 também
ajuda tá bom esses são os
principais esse novo medicamento para
TDH na sua opinião tem mais deficiência
do que os demais
não esse atenta aí que você tá falando
eu não tenho experiência com ele não
tá boa noite falou certinho sobre a
corrida em diária todos os dias em alta
intensidade causará lesões né até
fratura por estresse Obrigado
Estela tem que fazer fortalecimento
musculação obviamente né a Estela tá
certíssimo aqui
relógio com baterias de Lítio pode
prejudicar coisas n nossas células não
sei Eu precisaria dar uma estudado nesse
assunto por não tomar K2 por causa da
soja eh como fazer para tomar
D3 não entendi não você pode utilizar
soja fermentada que é rica em K2 tá que
é Nat ela não faz mal não tá a soja não
fermentada que que é o problema tá
bom Como fazer para tomar vitamina D3
vitamina D3 você vai produzir com
exposição solar os alimentos não vão ser
suficientes para você poder ter vitamina
D
suficiente Você conhece a a seiva sangue
de dragão Já ouvi falar mas nunca usei
Tá mas até hoje um paciente comentou
sobre isso por
coincidência quais seriam as aplicações
da seiva sangue de dragão quando
ingerida parece tem efeito
antiinflamatório interessante para dores
musculares bem ess essa tua pergunta
aqui eu vou dar uma checada
Nisso porque eu nunca vi a respeito
é Obviamente você não vai chupar bateria
de lítio né Isso você não vai
fazer mas só manusear a bateria de
lítio não sei se
seria o suficiente né logicamente não
vai engolir uma bateria de
lítio poderia ser até ser
Fatal se ela for danificada a bateria
Pode liberar substâncias tóxicas então
evite totalmente isso de ter contato com
bateria
danificada o descarte inadequada a
bateria Pode liberar metais pesados e
contaminar o meio ambiente
mas Aparentemente o manuseio normal da
bateria não vai gerar maiores problemas
não tá aparentemente eu teria que tá
vendo isso com
mais
atenção eh pessoal vou encerrar a Live
então Obrigado pela presença de vocês eu
vou talvez ver esse modelo porque tá
aumentando muito o número de perguntas e
tá se estendendo eu não queria que essas
lives passassem de uma hora não então
talvez das próximas vezes eu vou direto
para as perguntas em vez de ficar
falando artigo tá vou deixar o artigo
pro final se der tempo abraço para vocês
um beijo no coração até a próxima